les criminels rivalisent d'imagination
pour faire entrer de la drogue en prison
leurs tactiques sont de plus en plus
sophistiqués d'ailleurs ils utilisent
maintenant des appareils volants tenais
comment des gens pas avec une violence
incroyable et un de ces drones
on a pu voir ces drones le week-end
dernier la prison de lol ouais on veut
pas confirmer qu'il ya de la drogue qui
a été livrée si mauvaise qu'on sait par
contre c'est qu'il ya un appareil volant
télécommandé qui était au dessus de
l'endroit où les détenus sortent à la
prison dole derrière qui est un appareil
qui a été décrit comme étant orange et
il faut dire que la prison de hull est
un bon endroit pour ça parce que au tour
ce n'est que du bois c'est une forêt
c'est le parc de la gatineau a fait
alors c'est facile pour le pilote d'un
de ces engins d'aller se dissimuler de
se cacher dans le bois ici les agents
n'ont pas pu récupérer l'appareil en
question
il semble que cette technique là est
utilisée de plus en plus dans les
prisons québécoises d'ailleurs on a mis
la main sur une note de service du
ministère de la sécurité publique qui
s'inquiètent des risques que posent ces
engins volants pour la sécurité dans les
prisons
on les décrit comme étant peu visible
pas qu'ils sont très difficiles aussi à
détecter qui peuvent servir à livrer des
téléphones cellulaires de la drogue ça
peut aussi servir à livrer des armes
dans d'autres occasions d'ailleurs cet
été il ya un micro de ronde qui a été
saisi à la prison de rivière des
prairies
il ya un verre qui avait été installé au
dessus de l'appareil et on ya trouvé des
stupéfiants imaginez alors ça prouve que
cette tactique là est très utilisé et
les agents correctionnels sent pas
outillée eux pour intervenir c'est ça
effectivement parce qu'ils même s'ils
ont réussi à en détecter un dans le ciel
à le voir ben nous on n'a aucun moyen de
le neutraliser cet appareil là on peut
écouter un porte parole du syndicat des
agents correctionnels qui croient que le
mystère pourrait les épaules et un pull
à 2 en finale à sculpter des favorites
et ce projet sera un moyen des deux
directeurs aux agents d'être il est
alors qu'on a pas d'autres sites on ne
sait pourquoi pas c'est malheureux il
faudrait faudrait en avoir des coûts
malheureusement
réseau correctionnel on n'a pas le
budget peut-être on n'a pas les
ressources puis on n'a pas le temps
passer et vous savez sinon ces appareils
là on peut se les procurer pour quelques
centaines de dollars dans des grands
magasins d'électronique s'est rendu très
très courant il faut dire que l'appareil
qui a été saisie à rivière des prairies
avait doublé une cinquante mètres
environ la de rayon pour la télécommande
ce qui est pas beaucoup une petite pile
mais y en a qui peuvent aller jusqu'à
une distance de 1 km imaginez alors ça
permet au pilote de se dissimuler
complètement et ça peut porter jusqu'à
300 g de matériel dans certains cas
alors reste problème qui sans doute est
pris très au sérieux
c'est incroyable comme l'histoire on
n'arrête pas le progrès comme on dit
merci